vous avez dit avec cette obligation
vaccinatoire qui ne dit pas qui ne dit
pas son nom j'ai eu le sentiment d'un
viol dont on ne veut pas prendre la
plainte là avec la troisième dose sous
peine de perdre son pass et ne pas
pouvoir travailler j'ai l'impression
d'être victime d'une tournante ça a
énormément réagit derrière il y en a qui
sont d'accord avec vous mais métaphore
c'est toujours fait pour à réagir 1 vous
avez fait ça pour pour faire réagir pour
faire ce qui est fort c'est pas pour
choquer non pour faire comprendre aux
gens qu'un sentiment c'est un sentiment
que le viol ce n'est pas forcément quand
dans une métaphore une façon littéraire
un viol c'est juste ça peut être une
atteinte simplement à sa liberté à sa à
son intégrité physique c'est pas c'est
pas forcément un viol enfin il ya une
définition littéraire dans la rose un
donc hier une métaphore c'est fait pour
mettre en exergue un mot qui est sorti
un peu de son côté justement et pour le
comparer à quelque chose pour le rendre
plus fort ce que j'ai voulu montrer je
voulais l'annoncer ce que j'ai voulu que
je veux dénoncer c'est que on n'a pas
été à lorient n'est pas une obligation
vaccinatoire j'ai fait exprès d'inverser
la vaccination obligatoire parce que
c'est un parce que ça nous a dit
justement pas son nom c'était très
réfléchie et pas du tout mon truc et
régis je veux je simplement alerter les
gens qu'on ne peut pas priver de liberté
comme ça avec un étage et a injecté un
vaccin dans les veines des gens sans
leur consentement et qu'il ya d'autres
manières d'agir que de les obliger par
un passant en plus c'est obligé vraiment
parce qu'en fait à son bien qu'on nous
fasse une obligation vaccinale qu'on la
fasse mais ils savent très bien qu'ils
peuvent pas parce que un vaccin qui
n'est encore pas qu'est qui ajuste une
cage une une acceptation des raids
provisoire ils vont en payer les
conséquences y ait des problèmes gilles
mais madame moi je suis extrêmement
choqué par vos propos je vous entends
parler de sentiments de métaphore est ce
que vous pensez qu'avec la douleur d'une
femme violée on peut faire du sentiment
de la métaphore vous ne pensez pas quand
même que la douleur variole moi je suis
contre les femmes violées et que je
pense pas qu'elle souffre c'est moi je
suis nir vous ne pensez pas quand même
que la douleur d'une femme violée c'est
immensément supérieur à la éventuelle
d'une pas si c'est ce que vous avez dit
vous égalisez les douleurs jeunes
égalisait à 6 mais non j'ai des facs
réalise quelque chose de violent
sacralisé quarry tous les tous les
sujets de société aujourd'hui sont
sacralisés pour qu'on ne puisse pas en
parler et ouvrir le débat je dire qu'il
faut arrêter de sacraliser les choses
l'histoire sert au présent et le présent
c'est au futur je dire si on ne se sert
pas de l'histoire si on ne se sert pas
des choses en élargissant le débat et en
arrêtant de se victimiser sur son propre
sort tu veux dire on ne pourra jamais se
servir de l'histoire on ne peut pas se
servir des choses il faut arrêter de
sacraliser tout au point que chaque mot
ne puisse plus servir et d'interdire
tout débat alors aujourd'hui des débiles
pour moi oui alors oui aujourd'hui c'est
le sentiment d'un viol en 2012 c'était
l'islam est dangereux pour la démocratie
ça c'est ça c'est ça donc pour vous
c'est tout mais deux ou trois ans vous
semble mais comme ça en théocratie et
dangereux pour la démocratie ou est pour
moi oui une théocratie et dangereuse
pour la démocratie l'importun qu'elle
peut se creuser et on m'a pris n'importe
lequel la loi sont n'importe quelle
religion
toutes les religions l'adil dogs à udine
islam mais c'est a concerné toutes les
élites toute la selle qui censurent
surtout celles qui sont plus les
théocraties au cours des dernières
vacances en aidant les gens sont plus
fines attention des rôles ya donc
l'ensemble des religions les reliques
valérie non mais véronique vous dites
que vous utilisez effectivement la
métaphore mais moi je vous le souhaite
et qu'il faut convoquer l'histoire qu'on
a le droit de le malmener l'histoire de
la compétition sur ce plateau ici on est
tous revenus sur notamment les
comparaisons que moi j'ai trouvé
absolument odieuses du du pass comme
comme étant on va parler de l'étoile
jaune etc moi je pense que et que
comparaison n'est pas raison et que par
ailleurs le pouce cette métaphore là ne
fonctionne pas du tout pour quelle
raison parce qu'un violent quand on est
quand on subit un violent c'est une
agression dans le but de détruire une
personne or un vaccin nous avons le
remettre en course et a dit plancher en
avant de gicler raisonnement charentus
mon raisonnement un vaccin qu'on compte
qu'on ait envie de la voir ou pas peu
importe après ça c'est chacun son libre
arbitre en revanche le but mais cette
idée tout à fait il est tout à fait
opposés au viol puisque le but du vaccin
et sang et de protéger sa sphère vous
opposez 2
avéré le plus tôt sera temps d'examiner
le problème quand ça aurait bien des
gens je veux dire moi je ne peux pas
l'entendre ça c'est moi qui décide de ce
qui est bien pour moi j'ai versé pas mon
voisin qui décident de ce qui est bien
pour moi c'est moi qui décide de ce qui
est bien pour moi or votre vaccin et les
formidables mais il ne protège ni de la
transmission ni de rien la preuve même
castex et les vaccinés et il est
contaminée et les les hôpitaux ça
commence à s'inverser donc arrêtez de
vouloir protéger à tout prix les gens et
envers et contre les gens sont
responsables on est responsable mais
beaucoup vivent sans liant et
pourquoi vous l'avez s'entraîner en
utilisant ces coupes ccc comparaison la
vous pouviez vous formulez différent
parce que pour choquer les gens parce
qu'à un moment il faut il faut leur
chaque et l'esprit pour qu'ils
comprennent à quel point ces médias la
guillaume même si c'est pas
politiquement correct ce que dit
véronique genest est elle dit tout ce
que beaucoup de gens pensent tout bas
marine évidemment que le mot viol c'est
une métaphore qui est certes violente
n'est pas si mal choisi que ça parce que
le vaccin je suis désolé c'est quelque
chose vous un cerf aujourd'hui quasiment
de force dans le corps et moi son coup
de gueule je comprends d'autant plus
qu'au bout de deux ans comme on l'a dit
après multiples mais n'en reste
barrières et autres vaccins on entend
encore parler de confinement dans toute
l'europe et qu'on va vivre on se dirige
vers une ouvrière et cardwell vaccinale
comme un passe navigo qu'on doit
recharger tous les mois dans quoi je le
comprenne un coup de gueule je pense que
les gens ont compris sont pas débiles
elle compare pas un vrai viol avec sept
considèrent comme le viol vaccins entre
guillemets c'est une métaphore